this video is sponsored by ace defender
move aside every other strategy
role-playing game because the gorgeous
ace defender is here to raise the
standard with turn-based rpg battles and
tower defense systems and over 40
chapters and 48 heroes to choose from
with two new heroes added every two
weeks it's pretty obvious that this game
is the new big hitter explore in-depth
dungeons and level up your heroes in pve
mode or take it to the arena and battle
it out with other players to show your
dominance in pvp their newest hero
brenda the demon spear has this wicked
ability to deal huge amounts of damage
in pve or pvp but also limit her
opponent's damage while recovering
health on her own ace defender is also
about to go live with a mysterious new
world called the realm of deities which
will introduce the abilities to build
your own castle develop technologies
defeat all kinds of monsters on the game
map alone or with your friends and even
train your own soldiers for conquest and
endless treasure if you're a newcomer to
the game then after you download the
game and play through chapter 2 level 8
you get 10 royal recruit tickets
completely free for use in the sky city
tavern so what are you waiting for
follow the link in the description below
to download aced defender for free and
immerse yourself in a beautiful new
world all from the comfort of your phone
and now on to the video
hey everyone bandit here you remember
the zora from twilight princess you know
the ones that were frozen solid in that
ice that you had to smash a giant chunk
of molten rock from death mounted
directly into on top of zora's bodies in
order to melt no no it wasn't dangerous
it actually worked quite seamlessly and
nobody got hurt well nobody except for
the queen of the zora but she doesn't
count cause she had already been killed
previously which is exactly what i
wanted to talk to you about in this
video why was queen rutela murdered
among other things but let's start with
that question when we first meet the
ghost of queen rutella she explains that
she was murdered by the dark ones or the
shadow beasts in order to make a
statement to her people and then her
people all got frozen solid and that's
literally all we know about her murder
but let me ask you a question don't you
find it a little bit strange that the
shadow beasts were so merciless to the
zora of all people i mean the beasts
themselves are shown to only show up
when they're absolutely needed since
they function as zen's elite warriors
meaning we only really ever saw them in
game when they were assisting with
draining the power of the light spirits
or the takeover of hyrule castle or when
they were trying to hunt down and stop
the hero of twilight which is a pretty
high profile job going so far as to do
things like attack kakariko village to
lure link there and then wait for his
eventual appearance they don't really
waste any time appearing elsewhere and
never pay the gorons a visit for
instance yet for some reason they showed
up out of nowhere and straight up
assassinated the zora queen and then
proceeded to immobilize the remaining
fishes kind of a double whammy the fact
that the shadow beasts only ever
function to directly serve zant's evil
intentions means to me that they follow
orders i think that's pretty easy to
believe so here's the first actual
question to answer why would xand order
the shadowbeasts to specifically come
and assassinate queen rutella great
question as a reminder zan's will is not
entirely his own he ultimately serves
and worships a god that gives him his
powers and that god is ganondorf rewind
real quick to the cutscene where
ganondorf is supposed to be executed but
by some divine prank of the gods he
instead survives then proceeds to kill
one of the sages before being banished
to the twilight realm which of course
led to zan's rise to power but that's
neither here nor there have you ever
taken notice of which sage ganondorf
killed on his execution day comparing
the symbols of the sages and twilight
princess with the symbols of the sages
in ocarina of time we can deduce that
ganondorf killed the sage of water now
any zelda fan that's been around since
before the breath of the wild boom about
five years ago knows that the sages are
powerful and they're the most powerful
when they use their powers together the
best examples of this would be in the
adult timeline when just two sages can
literally pray the master sword's full
power into existence or in the fallen
timeline where the seven sages are the
ones who seal ganondorf within the
sacred realm no hero required because
he's dead anyway what if ganondorf knows
about the sage's potential power when
combined and is pretty grateful that he
was able to kill one of them now in the
child timeline the sages take on a
pretty majorly different appearance from
their adult timeline counterparts which
implies that they are not individually
the same sages from ocarina of time i
mean this guy doesn't really look like a
goron now does he this makes sense
though because link is the one who woke
the sages up in the adult timeline
events of ocarina of time so if those
events never happened in this timeline
then those individuals would not have
had to become sages of course this begs
the question as to who these other sages
are in twilight princess but that's
another theory for another day i'm going
over all this to state that the sages
from ocarina of time logically would
have never become sages and instead
would have lived out their lives
normally in the child timeline
everybody's still with me okay awesome
now back to the zora don't you think
it's a little strange that there's no
zora king i'm pretty sure that this is
literally the only iteration of the zora
that doesn't feature a king which just
seems like a very telling detail to me
and i think it implies something very
interesting when we take some other
evidence into account according to mr
zelda himself agonuma in a 2007
interview with nintendo dream twilight
princess took place quote in the world
of ocarina of time a hundred and
something years later so somewhere
between one and two hundred years if i
understand the english language
correctly this is pretty telling because
you know how long zora's live as
evidenced in oracle of ages which was a
game that came out before twilight
princess by the way the king zora in
that game has been alive for more than
400 years or by sidon from breath of the
wild who was a new baby a hundred years
ago and just now looks like a young
adult we know that the zora people live
for centuries plural so that means there
is a very big possibility that some of
the zoro we see or hear about in
twilight princess could have been around
in ocarina of time or vice versa that
the zorro we see in ocarina of time
could still be around or referenced in
twilight princess and wouldn't you know
it later on in that very same interview
how numa was asked if the king zor that
was referenced in the game was the same
as the kingzor from ocarina of time
whose actual name is dobon the third by
the way how numa then confirmed that the
mention of the king zora was in fact a
reference to the king's aura from
ocarina of time meaning that when rutela
mentions the late king zora she's
talking about this guy
[Music]
now things are getting a little bit
weird i mean onuma must have made a
mistake right if the dead king zora from
twilight princess is the same as the
king zore from ocarina of time which
does make sense unless two zora king
somehow lived and died in the hundred or
so year span in between games which is
unlikely then why didn't we see rutella
his wife in ocarina of time or why don't
we see his daughter ruto in twilight
princess who wasn't that old in ocarina
of time and should still be alive
something smells fishy here and it's not
just the queen well there is one more
thing i'd like to point out before
stringing all this together into a nice
little bandit zelda theory remember that
rutela gives link the zora armor in the
game telling link that her late husband
was the one who made the armor and
tailored it specifically for link well
this made perfect sense and no one
questioned it until breath of the wild
came out which revealed to us that
according to muzu the old grouchy zora
royal instructor for princess mifa quote
countless generations of zora princesses
have gifted that armor to the one they
have sworn to marry now it could be that
nintendo was retconning this old lore
from twilight princess which was that
the zora armor could be created by not
necessarily the zora princesses or that
they simply wanted to change it but for
all intents and purposes it does seem to
be a proven fact that it is a zorro
tradition for the princess of the zora
to craft this armor for the one they
want to marry not the king add this to
the fact that when rutela opens her
husband's grave which is oddly set in
some unknown location there are no bones
in the grave but rather just the armor
so okay what's really going on here let
me recap everything we've talked about
real quick before drawing a conclusion
we've got less than 200 years passing
between ocarina of time and twilight
princess we've got the zora lifespan
lasting no less than 400 years we've got
the zora king possibly confirmed to be
dobond the third from ocarina of time
nowhere to be found we've got rutella
specifically hunted down and murdered
after ganondorf killed the sage of water
and we've got zora armour specifically
crafted for link hidden inside rutela's
husband's grave you know what i think i
think that this all means that queen
rutela could be the daughter of princess
ruto or more likely due to there not
being that much of a time lapse in
between games that rutella is princess
ruto herself who rose to power as queen
following her father king dobond iii's
death this would explain why ganondorf
would command zand and his forces to
specifically target and eliminate her
since she would be the only person in
all of hyrule that could replace the
dead sage of water and restore their
combined powers as she did in the adult
timeline there's a little bit of audio
and visual evidence for this too her
theme is a remix of the serenade of
water which alone heavily implies a
connection and if you look at her
appearance you'll notice that with her
full dress-like fins and wavy hair if
that's what that is she was designed to
look like a more mature motherly
middle-aged individual if we take
sidon's aging pattern which appears to
take about a hundred years to pass or
let's say 15 years worth of visual human
aging then one to two hundred years
would mean that a zora would appear 15
to 30 years older to us right well since
ruto seems to be about the equivalent of
15 to 16 years old in visual human terms
in ocarina of time with the skirt like
fins and short hairstyle if you want to
call whatever that is that then she
should look about 30 to 40 years by the
time of twilight princess which is
exactly what rutela was designed to look
like and if you look at her necklace
you'll notice she's wearing what looks
to be the zorus sapphire the odd thing
is ruto herself said that she would only
give the stone to the man she wanted to
marry calling it the zora's engagement
ring the fact that she might have it
here implies to me that she never
actually gave it to anyone meaning she
probably never married meaning she never
actually had a husband which would mean
that she not her husband was the one who
followed zorah tradition and made the
zora armor for the man she loved who in
this case would be link but you might be
wondering how could she love link if she
had never met him and that's a very good
question that doesn't appear to have an
answer until you remember an extremely
important detail and that is that if
rutella is ruto she's met the hero of
time before in this timeline remember
when link was sent back in time at the
end of ocarina of time well most people
just assume that link was sent back to
before any of his child timeline
adventures happened because that's the
easiest answer but that can't be the
case notice where zelda sent him back to
he was sent back to the chamber of the
master sword beyond the door of time
meaning the door of time was open and
that door would only open if all three
spiritual stones were brought to the
temple of time meaning link must have
already completed jabu jabu's belly and
received the zora sapphire therefore
meaning that link must have already met
princess ruto who gave the stone to the
man she wanted to marry link after the
hero of time explained everything to
zelda including the wrongs that
ganondorf had wrought on the various
peoples of hyrule and it was then
determined that ganondorf was trying to
enter the sacred realm beyond the door
of time the door was most likely shut
and the spiritual stones returned to
their people groups thus explaining why
rutela has her spiritual stone back
after all these years and after the
events transpired she crafted armor for
the one she loved the hero of time in
case he would ever decide to come back
to her and accept her proposal but he
never did and when link received the
hero's tunic and feron the light spirit
says that those are the exact clothes
that the legendary hero who in this case
would be the hero of time war so it
makes sense that the zora's armor which
was crafted by rutela for the hero of
time would also fit his descendant the
hero of twilight there are still a
couple questions remaining that are hard
to fit within this theory though and the
first big one is what about rutela's son
we have no reason to believe that she
adopted this child and it seems unlikely
that a queen would bear offspring out of
wedlock so doesn't that imply that she
married and had a kid it does and i can
only speculate without evidence as to
how this could have happened if she
never married according to this theory
and that is that it's possible that
rallis could actually be her brother
just much much younger than she is if
her father the king passed away when her
little brother rallis was still a baby
and if her mother was not in the picture
she might have adopted him and raised
him as her own son if there is a large
gap in between the ages of siblings this
does actually happen sometimes in real
life and it's even encouraged since it's
still within the same family it's also
worth noting that rallis never mentions
his father and the symbology of mother
and child rock formations in the zora
region implies that his father was never
really a part of his life which could be
the case if the king had died when
rallis was very young leading to
potentially his much older sister
adopting him as her son queen and prince
there is also the fact that this idea of
sister caring for brother as a mother
would a son is somewhat parallel to mifa
and sidon's relationship in absence of
their mother but i digress like i said i
can only speculate as to how rutella
would have a child if she really were
ruto but explanations can be created the
final question to explain would be if
this is all true then why would rutela
lie to link and tell him that her
husband crafted the armor well let me
answer that by flipping the question why
should she tell him that she crafted it
for his ancestor especially if the hero
of time never returned to her to accept
it it's not like mifa gave her zora
armor to the hero of the wilds since he
never showed interest in her her father
had to give it to him a hundred years
after her death perhaps the answer is
simply that she hid this fact because of
her own pride i mean ruto was a pretty
spunky individual when she was younger
and she might be embarrassed if people
found out that she crafted this
intricate romantic gesture zora armor
for a hylian man that never came back to
her same as mifa so instead she decided
to place the armor in a hidden grave and
claim that her quote unquote husband
crafted it for the hero but that's
enough speculation for now i'll admit
this isn't a foolproof theory at least
not yet but i do definitely think that
rutela is either ruto herself or her
immediate daughter ultimately because of
the short amount of time in between
games but if she were her daughter then
you'd have to answer where ruto is and
who the father is and that's just a
whole other speculative theory in and of
itself that's even harder to believe
this has been of course just my theory
what did you guys think is rutella
actually ruto who crafted the zora armor
for the hero of time who never came back
for her or is rutella the result of some
good old zora lore retconning from
nintendo let me know in the comments
below also thank you so much for
watching i really enjoyed delving into
twilight princess again since it's one
of my all-time favorite games so please
consider leaving a like if you also
enjoyed this video and remember to
subscribe if you haven't already because
really you're going to want to stick
around i make videos about all sorts of
amazing franchises all of which are
pretty interesting huge thanks of course
to my bandit crew and a warm welcome to
lord omega who just joined up if you're
interested in doing the same please
check out the join button or patreon
links in the description below that's
all i've got for this one so as always i
hope you have a wonderful rest of your
day this is maskington abandoned looking
forward to seeing you next time and
signing out
[Music]
me